chandus name on you one he's not here he
doesn't care about you now Christopher
let me before we even start talking I
want you to know I'm a big fan buddy I
mean if I have to make a Mount Rushmore
a professional wrestling I'm sure you'd
being like my third and fourth
installment and that's big that's big
but I heard from a little birdie
Christopher that you wanted me to join
the inner circle
it's kind of interesting that you say
that Maxwell
because I heard from a little birdie
that you wanted to join the inner circle
[Applause]
Christopher I'm starting to think that
you want me to join the inner circle max
long started that you want to join me in
something that you want me in the inner
circle then we're getting it you want to
join the other side we're getting
repetitive now we're getting repetitive
now listen crisscross applesauce I'm
sure you'd really love me to join your
little inner circle jerk sorry sorry boy
you flip Freudian slip buddy all respect
to the champion sorry let me take a step
back Christopher I heard you like to
partake in well a little bit of the
bubbly
[Applause]
but I'm starting to think just like all
of these inbred
white trash redneck kids
you might enjoy drinking a little too
much just for you to assume that I am jf
the youngest and fastest rising star in
the history of professional wrestling
needs you that's just a little odd will
they tell you this the Maxwell C sells
seashells by the seashore
it's funny because I think that you
might want to be a little bit like Chris
Jericho is that true
think about it thing well we're both
from Long Island both have three-letter
nicknames both love scarves funny guys
crushingly handsome it's almost like
your parents got horny while they were
watching me beat up huva Tudor era 25
years ago ah WCW Saturday night and nine
months later your little toy facts
popped out I have to laugh
[Applause]
who the hell is goofy google it maybe
google it boy because this I can
understand why you'd want to be in the
inner circle cuz just being in the ring
with Chris Jericho puts you on a higher
level doesn't it Mac so let me ask you
once again do you want to be in the
inner circle
I don't know Christopher do you want me
to be in the inner circle I don't know
do you want to be an inner circle no do
you want me to be in the inner circle
Chris
I'm gonna say this one more time do you
want to be in the inner circle you want
me to be in the inner circle Chris all
right you know what you know who the
biggest jackass is oh no I know who the
biggest jackass
Jodi Rose oh there's some funny oh did
you gonna cruise together the worst game
of who's on first I've ever seen